[Music]
two more coming right up Lucky's got all
the luck yeah she's pretty no not bad
lucky just shipping out tomorrow he's
going to be a stone stow away for the
rest of us will still be playing
practice missions over Nebraska don't
worry we'll be over there droing bomb
soon enough Bucky next round's on us
he's never done that before so you're
Bucky and he's Buck uh that's a long
story they make a nice pair don't they I
should have introduced them earlier he's
leaving tomorrow everyone needs someone
to ride to back home I don't know if
John Egan's the pimp pal
type well maybe if you met a girl wor
writing to you would be a girl wor
writing to is hard to find not if you
know where to
look I see what you mean so you're right
me I already
have you wrote me a letter yeah what's
it say well you have to wait and find
out when will that be my ship out I'd
say 2 or 3
weeks miss
you all right right a toast Buck mod hey
you love birds we're toasting Bucky over
here for our new erac
Bucky all the drunks and the hundreds oh
someone's got to make a nest for the
rest of you Doos cheers major to the 100
best of luck sir good luck sir thanks
save we're going to slooter you guys
coming I got to fly early fck I don't
think so boys see you tomorrow then bye
M Bucky see you in England remember when
extra blankets and caught with a view
consider it
done he won't tell me what's with the
nicknames spil Mar go ahead go it's a
long story well they met in basic
training before the war
started John uh John was always Bucky
since he was a kid right that's right
yeah and Gail well Gail's always been
Gail until first day of basic training
this fell walks up to me and says that I
remind him of a guy back home in uh
Wisconsin goes by the name of buck I
tell him my name's Gail Gail clevin and
uh Bucky here he's not deterred no sir
it's uh it's just buck this buck that
buck and you help me timee my shoes Buck
help me fly this plane before I know it
the whole damn ath Air Force is calling
me buck so kind of a name is Gail anyway
you know what you you know what you
should actually be thanking me I did you
a favor forgive me the same name it's
not exactly the same name it's not my
fault you look exactly like Buck from
man it's Wisconsin what kind of man does
that to his best friend a it's so sweet
we need music okay don't go away
girl buck you're going to dance with me
before this night is still oh don't make
me dance
March pick a good one are you sure any
good hey you
know I am amazed that we're friends you
know to dance with a beautiful woman you
don't drink you don't gamble you look
like sports wow we are one of life's
great
Mysteries oh I love that yes
[Music]
yeah so this is it
this is it see you in a few weeks if I
don't die first hate to break it to your
Bucky but you are the hundreds air
executive now not going over there to
fly
missions look I uh I had a conversation
with the c over at the 389th and I'm
flying with those boys until you guys
show up I'll be an observation
pilot you son of a yeah well
someone's going to taste a little combat
tell you what it's really like up there
well thought youd die on me before I get
over
there don't count on
[Music]
it take the Lo down let's get this fire
out come on Faster come to help
us
[Music]